Dramatic moments ago,
just moments ago
in a Buffalo, New York, courtroom
where the man who shot and killed
ten people
at a grocery store in
Buffalo is now facing sentencing.
Barbara Massey,
the sister of one of the victims,
as we see that unfold.
Do we know who this man was?
We don't at this point,
but obviously the audience was filled,
filled with a lot of family,
a lot of people who
were directly related,
either friends or otherwise,
with with the people that were killed by
Payton Gendron, who,
of course, he's been convicted of that
at this point.
And look,
we knew this was going to be emotional.
We knew that
they were going to be up to 17
people who were going to speak obviously,
this is a tragedy that has shaken
not just Buffalo,
but places
across the world, too, to its core, but
especially in Buffalo.
But but to see this
level of anger
was something
I think you can see the surprise
on a lot of people's faces
when this happened.
But obviously right before that,
the victim impact
statement was being given by Barbara
Massey was already emotional
she wasn't speaking into the mix.
She was turned
and speaking directly at Payton Gendron.
She wanted him
to understand what he had done
to this community.
To these people,
to these loved ones, for for everyone
that was sitting inside of there.
Another thing was that now
now the hearing is
is back on track,
we should say, that the judge
trying to get things back
under control
did acknowledge
that we know this is emotional.
We know that this may be difficult
for people to hear.
But but please leave the courtroom
if you feel like you can't control that.
Also saying that
that we are better than this
as far
as acting on some of those
aggressive emotions, perhaps
but obviously it's
indicative of what we are
dealing with in the sentencing hearing.
And those moments are among
the most dramatic
I think I've seen in recent memory.
I've got to say,
I'm amazed it doesn't happen more often.
I can only imagine the anger
and the hatred of the people
involved there.
Omar, thanks so much
for bringing that to us.